welcome to episode 78 of the michaela
peterson podcast
this episode is featuring sal from mind
pump
podcast this was the first episode i
filmed when i got to dubai
and i had set up my podcast equipment
which was actually kind of complicated
and a cord came loose
and the camera didn't work and sal was
very very very very patient with me
i had him on because he's recently
published a book called the resistance
training revolution
he was also one of the first podcasts i
ever did we spoke about his experience
growing a podcast
and becoming quite successful online how
to stay motivated to get fit
sustainable discipline training and more
he has the number one fitness podcast in
the world
remember to hit subscribe if you enjoy
this content
this episode is brought to you by true
local tru
local.ca it's where i get my meat i've
been in dubai
not putting in anybody's face i'm
actually pretty pleased to be here
but i do miss the meat i get from true
local in canada
it's hard to find meat that isn't as
aged here and i don't like aged
meat with true local you choose what
goes in your box and they send it to you
flash frozen
super high quality they connect with
local farmers and then you get to buy
farmed meat sustainable nutritious
delicious i recommend their grain-fed
beef
i like the taste better wild salmon and
their lamb is
bomb code mp for free steaks in your box
mark the ceo has been one of my best
supporters and was sending me meat when
i was actually having a hard time
affording it
so i like him quite a lot tru
local.ca codemp for free steaks with
your box
enjoy this episode
[Music]
sal welcome to my podcast thank you so
much for joining me
i'm so happy to see you again yeah
thanks for having me on i was just
saying off air how it's been awesome
watching your your podcast do so well
it's pretty great thank you very much
it's been a lot of hard work uh we just
spent
30 minutes fooling around with cameras
but sal was very patient and now i'm
kind of sweaty
yeah don't worry about you know it's
happened to us and um and so i
and they've given me grace so i'm like
okay if this ever happens in someone
else i'm going to make sure i
i'm cool about it cause i know how
frustrating it is on the other end so
don't worry
okay sal if anybody doesn't know who you
are can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is that
you do
yes so um so i host i'm one of the
co-hosts of the mind pump
podcast so we're the top uh fitness
podcast
um in the world um and before that i was
a
a trainer and a gym manager um fitness
coach and i did that for over
two decades and then recently i just
published a book
called the resistance training
revolution most people know me through
the podcast through my pump
so is your podcast the actual number one
fitness podcast or are you just one of
those people that puts
number one podcast in their instagram
bio yeah like when you go see
when you go get coffee and it says the
best coffee in the world no
um no no we are actually we're i know
we're the
with the most one of the most downloaded
generally speaking in the world
definitely number one in the us
uh typically one of the top uh around
the world but we consistently rank
um at round number one um in fitness on
itunes and spotify
that's crazy yeah it's a lot of fun it's
definitely a lot of fun you know
when you listen to the show what you
hear are
three uh trainers we're not media
personalities i mean i guess we are now
because we've been doing it for
about six years but we're three uh
trainers who worked with people for you
know decades so what you hear
is uh us communicating fitness through
a lot of experience so we talk about you
know how
what really works and how to apply what
really works and i think when you train
people for as long as we did
one of the main things that you learn is
how to communicate
uh what you're trying to communicate
that's very very important you know the
information's out there you can look it
up online
how to you know lose weight how to get
fit all that stuff but
um what you learn as a coach is really
how to communicate it and how to get
people to the point where it becomes uh
permanent
um because i i know a lot of people have
gotten fit and lost weight and done all
that in the past
but the trouble is uh maintaining how do
i stay how do i how do i develop a good
relationship
with fitness and with nutrition that'll
last me forever that's the challenge
and we figured out a few things working
with you know i guess between the three
of us probably thousands of people
so what you hear on the podcast are just
three non-media
people who've got a lot of experience so
it's uh it's very
uh i guess i don't know real um uh but
uh i guess very effective people
it seems to resonate uh with a lot of
people okay i've got a bunch of things i
wanted to cover but um first off just
building on that
in your book you cover discipline and
how people sometimes
cycle between being super unhappy with
their body and
working out and then being like you know
what i'm just gonna love myself anyway
and then eating whatever they want and
then just going through this cycle over
and over again
so do you have any tricks for trying to
maintain discipline
yeah um there's there's a couple false
paradigms that have been pushed on us
uh or advertised to us i would say
through the the fitness and health space
one of them is that what what is
required
for long-term success
in fitness or long-term success with
good nutrition
is a high state of constant motivation
and this is how they motivate you this
is how they excuse me advertise to you
right
get you hyped get you motivated and this
is how you're going to stay consistent
well that's just
uh that's just not true motivation is a
state of mind
and like all states of mind it's not
permanent so there are times when we're
motivated
and i've never had to convince a client
to eat right or exercise
when they're motivated it's actually
quite easy we've all been in that
motivated state where everything comes
easy we want to do everything
it's when we're not motivated that it
becomes a problem so what you see with
most people's
if you look at the average person's
fitness journey
it's like this it's this up and down
when i'm motivated i'm consistent i'm
doing great when i'm not motivated i'm
not and the end result is
i've gone nowhere or even this slow
backwards crawl
into worse and worse uh health and
fitness the reality is this took me a
long time to figure out michaela as a
trainer i mean when i first became a
trainer i thought
motivation was key and i was the
motivated you know trainer i was the
the boot camp guy and i'd get people
hyped and you know after about five
years of doing that
i had an honest conversation with myself
and i said you know
am i really helping anybody i mean yeah
people get in shape when they're working
with me
but are people staying this way forever
and the answer was no
i was failing most the time and so i had
to
really change the way i approach it
really what you need to do
is you need to stop focusing on that
motivated state of mind
and rather learn to develop the skill
of discipline and the great thing about
discipline is is exactly that it's a
skill it's something that you can
build upon um and the strategy looks
uh you know the specifics are different
from person to person but generally
speaking
the way you build discipline is to start
with an honest conversation with
yourself so
you have to identify if you're in a
motivated or non-motivated state of mind
but when you when you do this
conversation because when you're in a
motivated state of mind
uh the stuff that you tend to commit to
tends to be unrealistic so to give you
an example
um when a person would come hire me uh
as a personal trainer and personal
training's
relatively expensive so they'd come to
me after probably thinking about it for
a few months
and they'd say okay i'm ready to i'm
ready to hire a trainer here's a
thousand dollars
let's do this and i'd say okay well how
many days a week would you like to work
out well i don't five days a week i'll
be here five days a week you tell me
what to do and i'll show up and it's
okay well
what were you doing before like how many
days a week have you been working out
on your own oh zero i don't work out at
all when was the last time you worked
out five days a week never or you know
five years ago or 10 years ago so i'd
say okay let's
let's start from here how many days a
week could you commit
to now that you know you could stick to
forever so i'd use that i would use the
term forever
um and it would change the conversation
and usually it would look like
one day a week or two days a week
so the key is to start with a
something that you know you can
realistically do
forever but it still needs to be
challenging it has to be
somewhat challenging because otherwise
it won't have any meaning if it's too
easy then it doesn't mean anything to
you
so have that honest conversation okay
can i do
one day a week and can i stick to that
forever realistically even an
unmotivated state of mind uh and if the
answer is yes okay that's where you
start then what you do is you start with
that
all right i'm gonna do you know mondays
at whatever time this is what i'm gonna
stick to
and then just do that just do that and
here's what will happen
over time it'll start to become
something that becomes a regular part of
your life
and there may be some hiccups up and
down but for the most part if you're if
you're honest
and you set a realistic goal then
eventually you'll get to the point where
you say you know what
i think i'd like to add another day a
week and over time you build this
kind of skill of discipline and i'll
give you an example of what i mean
because this is very individual from
person to person but
i have this one client i bring her up on
the show often um because it's one of my
favorite examples but
i i know i don't use her real name but
hopefully she doesn't listen
but she was uh i mean one of them one
loved her i love her to death but she
started out as one of the most unhealthy
people um i've ever met she didn't drink
water
okay she literally had no water at all
throughout the day she drank
diet coke that's what that's how she got
her fluid that used to be me
yeah really yeah that was it yeah no
nothing else
diet ginger ale oh man so i so we sat
down and we did this
and we set some realistic goals and
where we started was literally um one
glass of water a day
this is where we started that's so that
was the first place let's start with one
glass of water a day
and then the next thing we added she
hated vegetables right so the next thing
we added
was one piece of broccoli a day well
anyway
over the course of three years she lost
30 pounds
she made tremendous progress and till
this day she's still consistent
but it would have never worked if i had
taken her from where she had started
to to all right you're going to work out
with me four days a week here's your
meal plan
no more diet coke you're going to just
do everything all at once
she would have totally failed so
discipline
is a skill you practice it you build it
over time but discipline is what carries
you through
those times where you lack motivation
which is
the times when we tend to to fail uh
it's when we don't have that motivation
so it's just
just build it over time yeah that's
great
uh small achievable goals so that you
can have those small wins
but yeah that makes sense absolutely
absolutely and you know um
this you see this echoed in a lot of um
you know other fields but not so much in
fitness you know
um for some reason and i know why it's
it's much sexier to sell the
you know lose 30 pounds in 30 days you
know message or here's your extreme
crash
way of getting where you want to go but
it fails it's it's
totally not successful studies will show
there's you know like something like 85
percent
fail right and i i would even argue that
some of the people that are very
consistent with the
hardcore application of exercise
nutrition are unhealthy in other ways um
they tend to be
on that orthorexic uh i would say side
so
but it's it's really it's the only
successful
approach that i've seen that works
long term except for maybe the
occasional rare
epiphany that someone might have when i
don't know they have a heart attack or
something and they you know they see
their laugh
their life flash before their eyes and
then they do change everything but i've
seen that happen i think one time
everybody else it's got to be through
the application of developing the skill
of discipline
i feel like that's kind of the category
i fell into with diet
you just went too far no it's just like
i'm gonna die
so i don't have an option and then yeah
and then every time i tried to cheat i
just got walloped with symptoms
so it was like even though i tried to
cheat i was like no
wham no wham so yeah
you know it's uh you're a great example
of another thing that um
that i i communicate in the book and
something that we communicate on the
podcast which is um
to focus on health rather than
on aesthetics or appearance and what i
mean by that is
you know in our space in my space so
much of what we do
um is focused on how we look so you know
i want to work out so i can look good
i want to dye it so i can look good and
we
we're very focused on the mirror and the
problem with that
is when you're chasing appearance um
more often than not you start to lose
your health
and then you lose your appearance um
when you chase health when you go after
the health
i'm eating in a way to make myself
healthier in a real way i'm exercising a
way to make my body and myself feel
better in a real way
you get a great deal of health and then
the byproduct the side effect of that is
you look phenomenal you're an ex a great
example of that i know you changed your
diet because you were focused on your
health
uh but i changed my diet because i
because i had this rash that was
i'm sorry to ruin this but i had this
rash and it started getting on my face
and i was like
i can't look like this anymore so it
wasn't even for
like what drove me over the edge it was
health because you know rashes are
health but
it was like it was vanity the fact that
it helped with arthritis and depression
was a total by-product
and then it also made me look better but
it was pure like this rash has got to go
sorry style thanks for ruining what i'm
trying what i'm trying to say
but yeah for for most people i mean i we
try to communicate that because if you
make decisions based off of health you
tend to make
uh the best decisions or better
decisions than if it was just
for uh you know for appearance
yeah fair enough do you think the type
of person do you think it depends what
type of person you are
for for how easy discipline is like
conscientiousness has got to play a role
there
some people have got to have it easier
yeah i do
um but i also think um you know i'll use
the example of um
you know maybe athletic ability there's
a i'm sure i know there's a genetic
range of of gifts for athletic ability
you know you have like michael jordan
over here and then
you have you know maybe someone over
here who can barely you know
walk without stumbling um i'm sure
there's a there's a genetic range of
natural um you know ability to develop
discipline but that being said
everybody can build upon the skill of
discipline
and wherever you end up at was far
better than
where you're beginning at so and you
know i
i do try to tell people to not focus so
much on
you know on on the things that you can't
control i think that's a losing game you
know it's like
you know if i'm trying to build muscle
like and i look at a bodybuilder like
i'll never build as much muscle as that
bodybuilder i'll never be as strong as
that
athlete well you know so what um there's
you have
your own potential and you're probably
not reaching
your own potential let's just focus on
that
yeah i quit playing piano when i was in
grade six because i
figured out youtube you know and the
internet and i saw all these
tiny like three-year-old asian children
just nailing mozart
and i was just like that's it i'm done
i'm never gonna be even close to that
and they're
three and i'm 12 which was a mistake
because i was actually pretty good at
piano but yeah
don't do that it's a bad idea yeah what
do they say comparison is a thief of joy
yeah but it it's also at least for me i
find it's also what encourages me to
grow
so it's tricky because you can't compare
yourself
to something that's absolutely
unachievable
but that is kind of like i find that
this is super unhealthy but i'll follow
maybe i should not do this i i follow
these really fit women on instagram
just to make myself like feel
slightly worse about how i am to
encourage myself to exercise more
so you don't encourage that kind of
thing it depends right
um i think the we're we naturally
compare ourselves
um to other people and especially to our
you know i think to ourselves how good
we did before versus how good we're
doing now
i think if it becomes your identity um
then you might have a problem so in
other words uh you know if i'm looking
at if i'm comparing myself to someone
uh who say is a better podcaster than i
am and i'm saying okay i want to improve
my skills while that person's a really
good speaker
they really communicate well i need i
want to get better that's different than
saying
um wow they're so much better than i am
i'm i'm garbage
you know i'm i'm not wor i'm terrible i
suck i'm not a good person
i think that's where the the trouble
begins so like when girls for example
compare themselves to
bodies online um it it very quickly
oftentimes turns into that you know
plus a lot of them aren't real which is
the shitty thing about instagram
that's the problem with actually
following influencers especially women
on instagram is a lot of their bodies
are just not real they're just edited
they are and i'll tell you what i'm in
the fitness space okay i
meet a lot of these uh fitness
influencers and whatever perfect bodies
and um so and i've also trained lots of
everyday people right
there are far more poor relationships
with diet
um and body image issues in the fitness
space especially the fitness influencer
space
than there is in the general population
so when i train general pop
there's food issues you deal with food
everybody has some kind of you know food
issue it's just the way our society's
kind of i guess our culture is but in
the fitness space in the health space
especially the
in the the influencer space extreme
problems big time problems fanatical uh
issues um you know
they may they may eat the perfect amount
of calories and macros
but they're obsessed and they um they
don't have good relationships with
people and they're very very insecure
so you you gotta you know i think we're
comparing ourselves to this perfect
picture and then we paint them as also
these perfect people but it's it's not
what
what it seems do you think that's partly
because of just how many followers
people have and how many eyes they have
on them
or do you think it's the type of person
that just becomes a
fitness influencer i i think they're
they're
really good at getting at advertising
themselves
um because that's kind of what it is
it's kind of like your advertising so
they're really good at that
and they're really good at painting and
narrative um so
just remember that you know it's almost
like social media
is relatively new um but
you know it's like it's like commercials
like when commercials first came out
i'm i can only imagine that you know the
first people to watch commercials were
like
oh wow this commercial says that this
soap is the most effective soap that
there is i'm gonna buy this is totally
true
and then when i was a kid you know in
the 80s and 90s by that point
everybody's like ah they're all full of
crap it's just you know nothing's
they're all lying it's all advertising i
think social media is like that i think
a lot of people
are are still being tricked but i
i think at some point we're all gonna
get to that point be like oh it's
it's all marketing it's all it's not
it's not real
yeah i wonder if younger people have an
easier time with it
i don't know it's it's a that's a good
question i don't know
i i see more especially in the fitness
space i see
uh more younger people
um confusing followers and attention
uh with real i guess friendships and
relationships
so and i have i have a 15 year old son
and 11 year old daughter
so it's a little bit concerning to me um
that it might replace real
uh relationships or there's that that
kind of that that potential there
but i don't know it's it's it's new so i
don't know
are you doing anything to monitor your
kids social media use
like are they allowed on instagram and
facebook oh
it's also it's been coved too so people
are isolated and they're naturally
gravitating towards something that's
already addictive
but what are you doing there you are me
asking no no
um my my son is on no he's on no social
media but he does go on reddit
and he does uh do youtube and i do
tell him that you know we do have
conversations about this stuff my
daughter she's not on
she's only 11 so she's not really on
much of it um
my wife is off all social media she
turned it all off
she was already kind of teetering and
then the election season happened and
she was like all right this is just
toxic so she's
off she's completely off everything i'm
on social media
as because of my business and to be
quite honest with you if i didn't have
my business i don't think i'd be on
there i really don't
wow you're like unicorns
most people are on social media are you
happy
is your wife happy happier now that
she's off
for sure totally it's weird you know
it's um
who was i having this conversation with
arthur brooks uh arthur i think i was
talking arthur brooks real smart guy i
love him he's a
expert on happiness and we were talking
about how
it's um it amplifies mob mentality
uh social media so it's like fear
you know explodes and rumor explodes and
the news cycle is even more in your face
24 hours a day which
um you know it's like it's okay it's
great to be informed but
um not to the point where i'm like
terrified
of stuff that's happening you know
hundreds of thousands of miles thousands
of miles away or whatever hundreds of
miles away
um so yeah i don't i don't know i think
like i said if i was off if if i didn't
do this business i think i would just
turn it off for the most part and but
then again you know i grew up
without social media so i don't know i
don't know how easy that would be for
for someone who's you know 10 years
younger than me
yeah i have no idea i'm kind of torn
about what to do
with social media with scarlett i have
an instagram account for her already but
it's private and it's just
well it's for family i upload pictures
to it so that they can see her
so i don't know if that's evil or not i
was already uploading pictures to a
different platform online and it sucked
so i switched over to instagram because
it was better
but we'll see how that works out okay
switching directions
i want to pick your brain for for uh
as much time as we have left uh okay
do you do fasted exercise or do you
recommend eating first or does it matter
uh very this is a very individual thing
so there's a there's a variance here
some people um work out better or feel
better
when they exercise in a fasted state
other people notice that they get a
little dizzy
or woozy or they don't perform as well
now studies do show
athletes do perform better when they've
had
like a carbohydrate protein meal about
two or three hours
before their performance or whatever
but i've noticed as a trainer there's an
individual variance i personally
i i do great fasted i work out in the
morning and
i don't eat anything before i work out
and i feel best when i do it that way
um so and again we're splitting hair so
you know the studies that talk about
athletes performing better
you know if you're not competing in a
sport or you're not trying to hit your
pr or whatever
and you feel better waking up in the
morning and having some coffee and then
doing your training just do it i think
uh we tend to get caught up on these and
these
nuanced uh differences when it comes to
fitness and we forget about the
the the big thing which is how do you
feel like what works better for you
okay next question if you have an injury
on one side of your body and you're
trying and it's healed and you're trying
to regain
strength is it better to do even
sided exercise or should you isolate
each side so you do the amount same
amount of exercise
did that question make sense or do i
need to no i think i know what you mean
so in other words uh let's say i injured
my right shoulder and now it's healed
and i'm ready to
start training it again um should i do
isolation on my right and then
to catch up yeah to kind of catch up the
lost strength yeah so two things this is
actually kind of interesting
the belief used to be or i guess the if
you will the the common knowledge or bro
belief or whatever was if you have an
injury on one side don't train
you know let's say i hurt my right knee
don't train the left leg because then
it'll go way past the right leg and then
i'll have this huge imbalance
studies actually show well here's what's
interesting studies actually show that
if you train
the good side you lose less muscle on
the injured side which is kind of
interesting so
um continue to train all the parts of
your body
that are working it'll actually minimize
the muscle and strength loss
in the injured part muscle memory is a
real thing
so when you are able to train that
muscle and strength that you had before
comes back very very quickly so to give
you an example
let's say it took you six months to gain
10 pounds of muscle
and then you lose that 10 pounds of
muscle due to an injury it will take you
a month to gain it back so it's not
gonna it won't take you nearly as
long as it did the first time now now to
answer your question
specifically um you're better off doing
unilateral
uh exercises oh you are yeah so what you
want to do
is if you want to balance out
faster i suggest using the weak side as
your guide
so if i can only do 10 pounds with my
right arm
then i'll do 10 pounds uh with my left
arm wait for it to catch up which
actually happens pretty quickly and then
go back to
your regular training interesting
okay yeah i'm just using you to figure
out how to retrain my
left broken leg with my stupid ankle
is it bad is it back are you able to
train again
i am it took it took a year and a half
for the swelling to go down in my ankle
after i had it replaced the second time
a year and a half it was like feet
are a pain because i guess they're at
the bottom of your body
it's still larger but so actually i
don't even know but it's working really
well now compared to how it was before
so i'm going back to the gym um
which is exciting oh good deal yeah i
would do balance and stability exercises
for that leg
uh i hate doing those things i've been
doing balancing exercises
for like my entire life for a stupid leg
i want to do
romanian deadlifts well okay so here you
go
um do the balance stuff at the beginning
of the workout and then do your romanian
deadlifts
so do 10 minutes 10 15 minutes of
that single leg stuff and then go right
into your unilateral
exercises you'll be fine okay cool
great that answers that question um
can i ask you some business questions
too sure
okay how did you guys start mind pump
when did that start
first and how did that start so we
started that six
about six years ago um so i met
uh adam who's my co-host um well we all
we all came from kind of the similar
from the same industry and we all
started at
in one uh gym organization so we were
all
top performers if you will at 24 fitness
so i knew of him but we'd never met
before anyway
uh about six or seven years ago him and
i start connecting
uh through social media um through
belief
of all things cannabis um he had
actually
uh left the fitness space and started
some of the first
cannabis uh dispensaries here in san
jose
at the time i had a family friend who
was fighting cancer so i did a lot of
research on alternative
treatments and ways to help her through
chemo and so we
met through that and started talking and
then we started talking
about uh fitness i had created a fitness
program that we were going to market
online this when i say we it was
doug my producer him and i were actually
partners at the time
sent it over to adam and said hey what
do you think about this he loved it
and we got on the phone and decided
let's start a podcast he brought justin
who's my other co-host
uh they were partners and the idea was
to
start a podcast uh in the fitness space
communicate just like we communicate to
our clients
make it fun and entertaining just like
we do with our clients because
uh you want people to enjoy listening to
you uh you'll reach more people that way
and the goal was
let's see what happens so we started the
podcast
and we we for a full year we didn't
monetize anything we just
watched our audience grow
getting feedback and we started to get a
lot of people asking us
um how they could support us you know
how can i support you guys can you guys
go on patreon
can you guys sell t-shirts like what
what can we do to help you guys
and so at that point we knew we were
providing enough value to turn it into a
business
and then we sold our first online
fitness program which is
maps anabolic that was a program that i
had created and we monetized and shortly
after that
we basically quit our day jobs and did
it uh full time and never looked back
damn that's so cool yeah it's a lot of
fun
it's been a lot of fun yeah that is fun
okay
i'm gonna i'm keeping tabs uh taking
notes
okay uh how do you feel
actually let's do this one instead what
are the effects that you know of stress
on the body
so stress is an interesting one right um
stress
uh is necessary to elicit
adaptations in the body physically but
but also emotionally and mentally
without stress
we tend to stay in our our comfort zone
and so does the body right so
when we're trying to improve our fitness
uh build
strength burn body fat improve our
stamina endurance
flexibility whatever you have to give
your body a reason
to use resources to to
to adapt to get your body to improve
in any which way when any of those ways
that you know i talked about and in
order to do that you actually have to
stress the body
a little bit so it's really no different
than like your skin tanning when you go
in the sun right you got in the sun
the uv rays stress the skin a little bit
and the skin
then your body says okay let's darken to
protect ourselves from further stress
well that's what happens when your body
gets stronger for example so stress is a
good thing
when it's appropriate now when stress
overcomes
your body's ability to adapt then your
body's only worried about
healing and it starts to put everything
else on the back burner
um so to use the example of exercise
let's say i go to the gym and i work out
and i'm trying to
let's say improve the the shape um and
strength of my legs
so i train them really hard and i think
to myself the harder i train them
the faster they'll progress the problem
is i've gone too hard and i've exceeded
my individual body's ability to adapt
well now my body's not worried about
adapting it just wants to heal
so what it ends up looking like is i
work out hard i get really sore
i heal i go back to the gym i work out i
got really sore i heal
and i i never improve i never get
stronger
i never noticed the the i never improve
the shape of my legs
essentially i'm stuck on this what's you
know this kind of recovery breakdown
cycle this this trap so stress
is a good thing when it's appropriate
when it's uh when it
exceeds your body's ability to adapt
then it can start to cause
a lot of problems um that being said uh
your body gets stressed from many many
different things so
um generally speaking you wanna maybe
imagine you have a stress bucket
and when that overflows that's it your
body can't adapt anymore and what goes
in that stress bucket um
argument with your spouse goes in there
uh
not sleeping enough that goes in there
poor diet that goes in there
i worked out that goes in there you know
my kid
is you know being a pain or whatever
that goes in there
so all the that stress goes in there
and when you're overflowing um
you add more stress to that you're not
going to get any
you're not going to get anywhere any
faster so let's say your bucket is
already
at the brim because you know
you got a newborn at home you're not
getting a lot of sleep
as a result your diet's bad and your
so your stress bucket's like up here and
you're like i'm going to work out real
hard
that's going to get me you know i'm
going to get more fit no it's not
actually you're going to make yourself
much worse off
so this is a very individual thing um
you can you can improve your body's
ability to withstand
certain amounts of stress um you know
like as your body adapts for example and
becomes more resilient to
physical stress then you can handle more
of it you know if you took someone that
was completely inactive
then 10 repetitions of bodyweight squats
might be the limit of physical stress
for their lower body
but if you've been training for a long
time then you could do
much more so you can in you can train
your body to
to be able to handle more stress but
this is something that you have to
assess for yourself and you have to be
quite honest
and uh in in in my space in the fitness
space i see a lot of people just overdo
it
all the time especially women i see
women overdo it quite a bit
uh in the pursuit of looking better and
they can't figure out why their body is
so stubborn why is it holding on to
this last 10 pounds of body fat why is
my skin not looking good
uh why am i sleeping why is my sleep
poor
um you know why is my libido low i'm you
know i'm running
every day i'm lifting weights all the
time and i'm on 1200 calories a day like
it's like well you're just your body's
overwhelmed let's back off
and give your body an ability to give
your body the the capacity at least
the space to adapt then you start to see
them uh
improve quite a bit so this is something
that you have to identify
for yourself if you don't um you're
going to be in trouble
and i'd say as a trainer i used to
communicate this to my clients all the
time
it's better to err on the side of too
little than too much
if you apply if you overdo it you've got
a
it's it's harder to backtrack now you
gotta let your body rest and
depending on how bad it is it might take
you months to get out of that hole
it's better to do too little and then
slowly ramp up
and have your body start to catch up
okay so your book you talk about 60
minutes a week
being being enough to
anti to be anti-aging and just to be
to be able to grow muscle so is that
true
yeah so um now we have to look at the
context of
uh of what i'm talking about here so i'm
in the book
i in the in the the title is the
resistance training revolution
the reason why i put revolution in there
is because i'm trying to
change the the paradigm around uh around
fitness
um in particular for the average person
who lives in
a modern society okay so let's let's
look at the context first before we
get into what you're talking about so
modern life
is uh very sedentary right so
we've done a really good job of making
life physically easy
so we don't move much in fact the
average person
walks so little throughout the day that
if they just walked for about 45 minutes
to an hour
they would double the amount of steps
that they took all day long so that's
how little we end up
moving so very very very sedentary
but simultaneously very busy our
schedules are packed
all the time um you know we kids bring
the kids here got work
gotta do dinner gotta and so we just
kind of pack our schedules with and then
the little bit of time that we have in
the middle we get we
tend to you know smash in more
distractions or whatever
so very busy very sedentary we're also
surrounded by
hyper palatable easily accessible
heavily processed
foods today uh the average american's
diet
is generally about 70 to 80 percent
heavily processed foods uh now you know
why is that an issue
um generally speaking there's and
there's a lot there's a lot of issues
there's a lot more issues than what i'm
gonna say but generally speaking heavily
processed highly palatable foods
uh makes us overeat they're just they're
designed to do that um
there's some really really good studies
that have been done on heavily processed
foods and they show that when you eat a
lot when you
when your diet is comprised of heavily
processed foods you will naturally eat
about
five to 600 more calories a day so we
have
a diet that makes us want to eat more
or a lot we don't move much and we're
very busy
so that's the context right so what
is the best form of exercise in that
context
well the the original paradigm or i'd
say the the
most popular paradigm around fitness is
burn
calories okay that's what you that's
what you want to do when you work out
you want to burn as many calories as
possible
and at face value this makes sense
weight loss and most people are dealing
with uh with weight that they want to
lose that's the most common goal weight
loss happens from an energy imbalance
okay so that means that
you know if i'm taking in so many
calories
i have to burn more calories in order to
lose weight or
taking less calories than i'm burning if
that energy imbalance doesn't happen
then weight loss
doesn't occur it's just it's a law of
thermodynamics now there's a lot more
detail that goes into it
and there's a lot of individual
variances in terms of what people should
eat
but that one general rule is is true
you burn more calories and you take in
and you lose weight you know burn less
calories you take in
and you gain weight so our thought was
let's just
if we work out for an hour let's pick
the form of exercise that burns the most
calories
that'll be the most effective way to
work out well it's not it's actually a
terrible
uh paradigm around fitness and here's
why
number one if you exercise intensely
for an hour and i mean intent you pick
the calorie burning form of exercise
running i'm gonna go run because that
burns the most calories
you're lucky if you burn about four to
five hundred calories
in that hour now i know treadmills will
say you burn 800 calories or whatever
they're lying
they're trying to get you to use their
cardio the truth is the average person
will burn four to five hundred calories
in a full hour of cardiovascular
hard cardiovascular activity now four to
five hundred calories
isn't much um i can i can eat that in 15
minutes i could drink that in five
minutes no problem
here's the other problem with that i
have to do it every single day
if i don't do that hour of intense
activity i'm not burning an additional
four to five hundred calories
here's another problem exercise
isn't just calorie burn it's also
telling your body
to adapt and get better at what you're
doing okay
so when i'm doing lots of cardiovascular
exercise okay yeah
what i'm telling my body to do is to
improve its endurance
which requires very little muscle
doesn't need lots of strength
in fact doesn't require much strength at
all needs lots of stamina but it's also
telling my body to become efficient
become more efficient become more
efficient over time
you actually burn less and less calories
doing that form of activity
and in fact if when you look at studies
of people who do this
when they look at their entire day they
stop burning extra calories your body
is really really good at becoming more
efficient and there's some really good
studies on
modern hunter-gatherers uh where they
find
that they don't burn that many more
calories in the average westerner
because it's i mean it's evolutionarily
speaking
it uh it makes perfect sense yeah so
think about it this way if you lived in
the wild and you're
you know a hunter-gatherer and you're
moving all the time right you're
chasing down your food and you're
gathering it doesn't make any sense for
your body to burn 6000 calories a day
it'd be very hard for you to find
6 000 calories to support yourself so
your body just learns to become
more efficient and so what it looks like
when you do lots of cardio or lots of
exercise to burn calories to lose weight
is you initially lose weight
and then you plateau real hard and then
you're doing an hour of exercise every
day to maintain it which
uh maintain that little bit of weight
loss which is
unrealistic for most people it's just uh
it's just most people
are not going to be consistent with
structured exercise
every single day just not we just need
to be honest so what we need to do is
shift our paradigm a little bit and look
at exercise as a way to
uh to get our bodies to adapt in ways
that are favorable
okay so let's look at resistance
training
uh lifting weights using resistance
bands using our body weight
in other words using resistance in a way
to build strength and muscle
what is the adaptation that happens from
that we build strength we build muscle
we speed up the metabolism so we
actually tell the body
to burn more calories as a side effect
of getting stronger and building muscle
if you build muscle if you train your
body to get stronger
your body's tendency is to burn more
calories more muscle burns more calories
but your body also becomes less
efficient with calories as you start to
trend towards getting stronger this is
why
uh you know somebody who's uh you know
five pounds heavier with more lean body
mass who trains for strength is going to
burn
maybe 200 more calories a day every
single day than somebody
who's not so resistance training
bur teaches your body to burn more
calories here's the other good part
about it
you don't need to do resistance training
every single day to do this
for most people a couple days a week of
resistance training the average person
is going to build muscle is going to
build strength so long as it's done
appropriately
and will result in a positive effect on
the metabolism so now you end up with a
metabolism that burns more calories
on its own and you've also had a little
bit more muscle
on your body which is very protective uh
to the body protective to
to uh you know in in the context of
being inactive
protective uh with uh you know insulin
resistance
diabetes alzheimer's so we just need to
shift our paradigm because right now
if the average person thinks to
themselves
i'm gonna start uh you know let's say
the average person goes to the doctor
and the doctor says
your blood pressure's a little high you
need to lose about 20 pounds
you should go start exercising the
average person will say
think to themselves you know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna go jump on the
stationary bike
or i'm gonna go to get on the treadmill
the average person doesn't think
they're gonna grab a pair of dumbbells
or go do some resistance training
that needs to to change because
resistance training is
far more effective uh again considering
the context of modern life
that's really interesting and totally
makes sense
yes and i'll tell you you know uh i had
tremendous i mean still
with our podcast we have tremendous
success teaching people this
this in part of the reason why this
message hasn't really been
effectively communicated is because
resistance training is
you know very stereotyped now when i say
i mean definitely with women but even
with men you know you get the average
man that just wants to lose weight if i
tell him
you should go do resistance training or
lift weights oftentimes i'll get the
reply like oh i don't want to get big
that's not my goal i just want to lose a
little bit of weight and get more
healthy that's got to be from
women especially from women especi
in fact women have suffered the most
from the
the way that the fitness industry is
advertised to them um
now luckily more and more women are
starting to see the benefits of proper
resistance
training or starting to do it i mean
when i started
as a trainer in gyms in the late 90s you
didn't see very many women at all
uh working out in the in the weight area
now you see
quite a bit more but still women are
still advertised not to lift heavy
weights
to do high reps to do circuits
essentially do cardio with weights
because it builds you know bulky muscles
and it'll make you look
you know a way you don't want to look
which is totally false um the way most
women want to look
is much you can accomplish it much
faster
and more effectively through resistance
training so
that's really the message of the book my
goal is to get people to look at
resistance training as
the uh primary form of exercise that
they engage in
and by the way i'm not saying there
aren't benefits to other forms of
exercise i think
a well-rounded routine will give you the
best overall health
results but knowing the average person
is not going to do more consistently
they're not going to consistently work
out more than two or three days a week
you know most people are not going to do
multiple forms of exercise
most people want to lose weight most
people want to improve how they look
and how they feel improve the hormone
profile you know
maintain it or whatever for those people
you're only going to pick one form of
exercise
pick resistance training
okay okay and if you're optimally trying
to grow muscle
in a short period of time is working out
more
doing more resistance training more
helpful like is doing five days a week
like logically that's going to grow
muscle faster than doing it two or three
times
even though in the long run you're
probably not going to continue doing
that um
it depends no um it depends on the
person the
when you're when we're talking about uh
resistance training and we're trying to
again we're focusing on the adaptations
that it
uh promotes um the appropriate dose will
get you there faster
so less than the appropriate dose will
get you there slower
more than the appropriate dose will get
you there slower
the right dose will get you there the
fastest
so if i'm taking somebody who is you
know
they're not fitness fanatics maybe they
work out here and there but they're not
like super
in the gym all the time and they want to
get there and they want to get there
effectively
uh oh my gosh two days a week done
properly
that's probably appropriate that'll
probably get you there the fastest
i mean it's funny you say that you know
my my producer doug
um i met him because he was a client
and he came to me with experience
working out five days a week and six
days a week and following all these
routines and i brought him down to two
days a week
and in his late 40s got in the best
shape of his life
doing that um so and i mean that's very
common right it's very common for us to
think if some is good more is better
this is not true with any form of
exercise
um but especially with resistance
training
wow that's really good news so is that
that's
that's really good news so is that like
two hours in the gym
twice a week or in your book you talk
about the 60 minute thing
so why why where's the 60 minute thing
coming from so for the average person
who is not really exercising
consistently
um two 30-minute workouts of proper
appropriate resistance training
fantastic we'll reap them phenomenal uh
phenomenal results we'll get them great
results
now at some point if they're very
consistent and they've been doing that
for a year and they feel great
at some point they'll need to increase
that in order to
uh to get their body to progress any
further but
most people um you know two 30-minute
like i said appropriately done
resistance training workouts
we'll get them there we'll get them
pretty far
wow okay that's very cool
um i need to go back on something i said
so i made a self-deprecating joke at the
beginning of the episode about the rash
on my face
yes that is what initially started my
research
but as soon as i connected it to the
autoimmune portion i went
like full head speed into overall
general health so that wasn't exactly
true but it is what initially started it
was
rash on the face appearance in in
aesthetics is what always gets people
initially there but the only
way to stay there consistently is to do
it through health because health is
self-care health is truly caring for
yourself
and that feels good when it's always and
forever about appearance
um it that's when you start that's when
you get the person who says
you know you talk to your friend you're
like hey are you still working out like
what's going on no i stopped working out
i stopped
the diet thing well how come because
they just want to enjoy life
you know like okay yeah and that's
because
you hated it because it was always
focused on appearance
when you're focused on health it's great
um you are enjoying your life and of
course and here's the other thing
you are more likely to make decisions
that are that are good
you know i'll give you an example okay
if you're always like oh my belly's
disgusting i'm fat i need to get this
fat off oh i hate the way i look i need
to whatever
and then you start working out you start
dieting or whatever and you're really
consistent because you're motivating
yourself through that
that paradigm or whatever and then i
don't know you fall off the wagon
you know you go out with your friends
you have pizza you eat a burrito
whatever
then the next day you wake up and you're
like i can't believe i did that i'm so
disgusting
i'm gonna go to the gym and i'm gonna
i'm gonna sweat it out i'm gonna beat
myself up right so you start treating
exercise like a like a punishment
the person who's focused on health might
say something like
oh man yesterday i ate some things and i
can feel
in my body they're not really i didn't
really do myself
that good so i'm gonna go to the gym and
i'm gonna take care of myself and i
don't feel very good right now so i'm
gonna stretch
i'm gonna go easy i need to you know
care
for myself or or they may say
wow yesterday i know i ate that burrito
on that pizza but i had a great time
with my friends
we really connected that was awesome um
but you know today i'm gonna go to the
gym and i'm gonna i'm gonna exercise and
i can't wait to do that again in four or
five weeks when i see them again
it's totally different and it's much
it's gonna your your the result and the
the irony of that is the aesthetics or
the appearance
the results are far superior uh
over the long haul by focusing on your
health so and i knew that's what you
were doing
yeah that is what i was doing i just
self-do you use
self-deprecating humor constantly
probably too much
uh okay i have like i just have a few
more questions
sure um if you if you had to tell people
to use one
type of like weightlifting exercise if
you could choose
or like top two what would they
oh man that's hard that's going to be
real hard to pick just to i mean i could
give you
let me give you let me give you some of
the best exercises and then tell you
kind of what they do right so
uh a squat is one of the best exercises
you could do it's a
it's a foundational uh human movement if
you can squat well
then you can you've got decent movement
uh
from a performance standpoint the
carryover is huge so you get good at
squats
you tend to get better at other stuff it
builds good muscle
it does work the entire lower body with
some
upper body activation um it's hard to
compare to a squat it's hard to have any
other exercise
really in the same category as a squat
and this is all squats so body weight
squats all the way up to
to barbell squats um an overhead press
is a great exercise it another
fundamental human movement reaching up
overhead
working on shoulder mobility we tend to
lose that as we get older um so i you
know towards the end of my career i
trained a lot of people in advanced age
and many of them could not fully extend
their arm above their head because they
had lost that ability
yeah oh yeah that's what that's from
okay yeah and it's it's you know it's
it's a really really
it's really great for the upper body for
the shoulders for the upper back the
arms
um some kind of a pushing movement
horizontal so it could be a bench press
could be a push-up
uh it's gonna be really good some kind
of a row
is going to be really good it helps work
on posture it really helps strengthen
the muscles that we
are we tend to have that are really weak
nowadays due to
working on computers and you know being
on our phones you see a lot of
forward shoulder posture you see that in
kids nowadays
um so some kind of a proper row so it
could be a barbell row a dumbbell row
a cable rope can be a band row will be
really good
so those exercises are probably up near
the top and then for your your core
you know a a proper physio ball
crunch or some stabilization like a like
a proper plank i say proper
because most people do it wrong it's
going to be good for for core
strengthening
and stabilization you know here's the
thing too i think there's uh
misconceptions around resistance
training that you need to do like five
million different
varieties of exercises you actually
don't if you just got good at those uh i
think most people would be happy with
their
with their the progress and the results
okay that was great what happens if you
can't squat can you replace that with
glute bridges or something
yes you can so uh i'm i'm assuming
you're asking for yourself because
you're limited ankle mobility
yeah that's why i use this podcast is
just just to learn things for me
no no that's great so if you have
limited ankle mobility
um you could do you could try variations
of
lunges that limit the ankle uh you know
ankle
extension and flexion you could try uh
you know step ups you could try machines
this is where machines come in handy
uh leg presses where your legs are real
high on the platform
might limit uh some of that ankle um you
know
like i said ankle flexion extension hip
thrusts
are are perfectly fine for the what's
called the posterior chain the glutes
and the hamstrings um so yeah absolutely
and in your case obviously he's not the
majority
but in your case you know if i was your
trainer we would assess and then we
would come up with some good
alternatives
okay thank you sal um if people
don't follow you where can they find you
online so you obviously can find
me through the podcast which is mind
pump um if you want to check out the
book
that is going to be coming out soon you
can go to the
resistancetrainingrevolution.com
and then if you want you can find me
personally on instagram
at mind pump sal
i would also recommend checking out the
program and i will link the program
below
and the book and your socials for people
interested thank you very much for
coming on sorry there was a
huge delay and a camera switch yeah
no problem and again i guess i
appreciate you i appreciate what you're
doing so
this is fun anyway thank you
we'll talk again soon okay
[Music]
you